hello and welcome to this video playing
coughs ooh again that's a back-to-back
and let's go into the Sicilian I played
a draw against too early again
if three is was a mistake yeah no way he
could have used that now we are back
into a normal line but that could have
been awful I have to play Bishop III in
this position I show you later that was
a pretty stupid to move water problem
okay here Queen takes a to assume you
have to play and no if you don't you're
going to suffer and we will see in this
game how this will look like cannot
primo folks eh
[Laughter]
I think I mentioned that before I'm not
sure when that was could have been a
chest 24 stream maybe oh it could could
have been on my channel but this has
this has many classic predecessors as
pollution the most no one won the game
poorly I have ski against if cough where
if cough suffered a lot a lot in that
game Bishop e2 was actually played which
is also a good move but g3 intending
Bishop h3 is even a bit stronger Black
has some problems in this position with
the C file with the bishop coming to h3
you cannot stay on c8 of this step and
you have a hard time to go to c7 as then
I take a 7 and if you imagine a 6 let's
say a 6 Bishop h3 root goes whatever on
the C file a playbook c1 that's the end
at the end is Bishop c8 and black simply
loses the Queen side yeah this is the
possibility but it's also yeah not not
the easiest position to play yeah here a
very simple way to do it is simply to
take one d7 and play rook see one it's
not the best dome you can go see one as
well that's interesting
if I just okay this and I go be three
okay the a7 is hanging he has to play
some color move now and then I play with
c1 and they have the C file maybe that
was not the most forcing way to do this
an SS reaction wrong
it was the most forcing way but maybe
not the most promising way so why can I
not just take this show me you have to
show me why
[Music]
you're just a pawn huh
why is there the rookin all that isn't
news just a pawn
yeah it seems that he wants to put this
onto a three so so how do we win this
now who could be one Bishop III before
that looks it's kind of convincing I
think you have more than one good
continuation here basically tried to
trap it
so rook b3 now there's Bishop c1 which
is just about holding something better
it looks kind of looks like I should
have more if I play what if I what what
what here if I don't this and I just
intend to play Queen King c2 King v3
isn't that trapped wait looks trapped
no G for peace
I cannot simply take it after King b3
because my bishop is hanging so I have
to play yet another prep move but it
should work
I think the bishop is gone I try some go
to e7 down okay so here if I get to the
C file now he has to basically use the
rook to to cover cover that and I can
mop it up on the other side of the board
you basically playing a piece down
that's easier
weird sounds him okay so um take it
okay so let's have a look them that is
um yeah there was some interesting
points I made a huge mistake with f3
that was a basically a finger failure
yeah because he can take only four and I
and I'm toast
that's very lucky of course I just made
a plate that's too quickly anticipating
somehow g6 after which I play of three
and this is I have two after this you
have to start with this move to give
additional protection to d4 so that was
a big issue really after the capture we
transpose back into normal lines and
here here black has to check on a two
that is the only move that equalizes and
it leads to some funky complications but
like this this it is okay for black you
have to know it and play it this is bad
it's really bad the problem is that
isn't working because of rooks is 7 yeah
they cannot take with the night and if
you have air you and how do you I mean
you have to take it and there's no way
to cover this that is satisfactory so
this is has to be played rook c8 can
take and now the mentioned game Polanski
if 20 should be 2 and then later rook C
1 will be 1 but G 3 is even stronger
with the bishop come up to age 3 and
here yeah the capture is actually yeah
it's given by the engine there are many
lines here that are better for white but
this is very straightforward he has to
now spend a tempo on a6 or something
like that and then I get the C file it's
it's very very tough to defenders white
invades on the 8th or the 7th rank my
king is closed I can go F
and try to invade and the bishop is not
doing much and the way it went I just
had to pawn and yeah technically winning
yeah now the bishop is cut off and I
think that is already losing okay I
missed something I missed this one that
is a nice nice idea and two pieces I
again that was quicker my witness is
more of a technical way but the bishop
is just not playing and now you win on
the other side of the board so this is
an interesting game for people who play
the black side of this opening here you
have to take a - otherwise you're
trouble thanks a lot for watching